en esta calle de dakar estos jóvenes no
podrán dar un paso más imposible
acercarse a la plaza de la nación donde
se iba a celebrar el mitin convocado por
la oposición ya que fue prohibido por
orden de la prefectura todos vinieron a
protestar contra la invalidación por
parte del consejo constitucional de la
lista nacional de la coalición opositora
y sangüi a las elecciones legislativas
de julio
debe rendir cuentas no puede salirse con
la suya los jóvenes se enfrentarán a él
aunque haya 200 nuevos imagina jugando
bajando moura léxico al presidente matiz
al que deja la gente ir libremente a las
urnas deben dejar libre a los humanos
son hop el es la esperanza de la
juventud
[Música]
los jóvenes acudieron a apoyar al
teniente alcalde ox manson con una de
las figuras de la oposición a la que se
le impidió presentarse a la reelección
él está tratando de negociar con estos
oficiales de la policía para llegar a
las oraciones del viernes aunque sin
éxito
la constitución dijo que tengo derecho a
ir a rezar esto es una violación de la
ley y la constitución es una orden
ilegal no culpo a la policía somos
víctimas de maquis al todo esto es el
resultado de un poder que tiene miedo
al igual que otras figuras de la
oposición oxman son co candidato de las
elecciones presidenciales de 2019 quedó
excluido de las legislativas el motivo
aducido es la inelegibilidad de un
candidato que aparece inadvertidamente
tanto entre los titulares como entre los
suplentes pero aquí denuncian un
estratagema para eliminar a los
opositores políticos que se han vuelto
demasiado peligrosos tras el revés del
partido presidencial en las elecciones
municipales de enero pasado una buena
docena de ministros altos cargos de
empresas e instituciones públicas
avaladas por el presidente fueron
arrastrados por el jewish en la sede
municipales de enero